[Music]
have you told Cody that you got the I
got the oh you want a gun what did you
buy what kind of gun got a gun I bought
the Bug Assault shotgun and then I got
the shredder okay which is a mock-like
uh six shooter look at that thing look
at the thing look at the shredder it's
got a small CO2 canister and you know
it's got the [ __ ] that rappers get high
on and what do you do with it so it's
got like kind of like a cap gun it's got
these spirals that you can load into it
and they're just pockets of salt it
shoots it with compressed air okay it's
good against roaches okay and there's
some construction near my place so it's
been filtering in like a roach every now
and then okay and um roaches are
disgusting you execute them I did have a
moral dilemma the other day and let me
explain but my initial motivation for it
was I liked the idea of getting to shoot
it from a distance so here's where I
played myself you can't shoot it from
that far away okay okay so you have to I
don't want to show this clip because I
can show I can show you two right okay
so the shotgun spray is a little
aggressive
okay it leaves a bit of a mess I think
of a roach like is is this thing
intended for well like why do you need a
shotgun well okay no no no the shotgun
is for the flies and that one it's it's
it's a bit more Ginger when it hits the
fly the power of the saw is not so
intense it's just like a peppering and
it like debilitates the Flies so you can
like pick it up with some tissue paper
it feels more Humane yeah the shredder
though uh I've killed a roach and a big
ass spider now and you'll just see from
the way I [ __ ] shot this roach let me
preface this bro with I heard this roach
in my garage I went out to take the
trash one night I went through the
garage and I heard him like shuffling
around in this like of this cart with
tools on it I heard him look like just
crawling I'm like I know your ass is a
roach let me get you later and I'm gonna
encounter you later in here I'm just get
you later yeah so my Shredder comes in
okay I hear this [ __ ] by the way
the tagline for this is Shred the [ __ ]
out of them I hear them rattling and
then I look over and he's crawling out
of the tool cart it's almost like he
knew yeah right my tools I opened the
door I go what are you doing in all my
tools I shout out to lean I'm like Elena
give me the gun she hands me the
shredder I see this [ __ ] he crawls out
and roaches move fast when's the last
time he killed a roach I don't think
I've ever killed them never like stomped
out a roach no what I just let him do
their thing
yeah
you're cool the last time I encountered
one was probably in Nicaragua I think
you just let it
yeah okay well I have a special Vendetta
because one of these roaches somehow it
made its way under my bed okay and he
like came out from the wood and I was
like what the [ __ ] how did you since
then his brothers and sisters are dead
to me okay I have a vendetta against his
family so this [ __ ] cockroach he
starts moving quickly and I
I'm shooting from far I don't really hit
him so I have to get closer so he like
he feels the air and he kind of starts
running underneath my car so as he's
making way under my car I get close I
didn't wasn't sure I get him I'm looking
under the car see him he's on the other
side of the car he's moving a little bit
slowly the [ __ ] compressed air sends
him
a good like two feet he hits the back
tire of my car then I like kind of move
him out with my shoe I literally shot
his ass off but it's a cockroach so he's
still moving but his ass is completely
shot off oh so I kick him out from the
garage and then I execute him oh God and
in the moment I never felt so evil yeah
so I'm gonna show you this all right I'm
just gonna
and you filmed yourself doing it too
yeah executing this guy
[Laughter]
I mean he [ __ ] exploded yeah and I
felt some dark energy when I did that he
exploded I got four bug bites this
weekend and I they're bad I just
accepted that's the animal kingdom being
like hey chill out yeah let me show you
the fly now the fly shotgun that has me
a whole different person I [ __ ] in the
kitchen now just so they will I leave
him fruit
I cut a mango and just leave it open on
the yeah kitchen yeah I'm [ __ ] in
the trash can that's funny
partner
holy [ __ ] sound is yes that's nuts what
does the salt do to them it just kills
them well it's sent as such like a high
rate I think it just damaged what
happens if you shoot a person with that
thing it says don't point it at a person
I'm sure it would really hurt I think it
would hurt especially the shredder we
should just do it and we have one flying
in right now what's this this for me
this for Dad that's a shredder thanks
Dad what'd you get a sandwich yeah I
ordered bread but they put a bunch of
[ __ ] inside it
it's taking out the chicken everything
the [ __ ] is all this in the middle the
bread a piece of bread yeah so I don't
know I have ham how much were they the
Shredder's expensive man it's like 100
bucks 100 bucks yeah I know I think I
saw an ad for this or something and
people were going like crazy over it and
I was like well I don't understand what
this is for but if it's fun to use
that's where okay so that's where I feel
evil
because it when I shot that cockroach
I'm like I'm a [ __ ] up person I want
to do it again
to a moose to a no no no no this thing I
don't know if I could ever upgrade to
like animal yeah I'm gonna get the Moose
vaporizer yeah
yeah oh you can get one of those it's a
bazooka no no no no no there's so many
places you can get that there's Ford
there's Kia there's Chevy there's
yeah I got the Ford F-150 moose
vaporizer with the snow plow on front
and I know people now are gonna conflate
my entertainment with killing a
cockroach with like you know
um the next Ted Bundy but no this
wouldn't exist if people didn't like
doing it you know the thing about
shooting off that roach's ass I felt bad
yeah you wanted to put it out of its
misery kind of that's why you exploded
it yeah yeah so what did you say in it
oh no it to the fly I said reach for the
sky oh yeah all right yeah but that's
because after I sent the first clip I
sent one to Siva and Siva [ __ ] put
the OverWatch you never you played
OverWatch no there's this [ __ ] named
McCree and he is like ultimate where he
like has like a a six shot he [ __ ]
melded that into the clips like it's
High Noon that's good yeah is this it
right here yes dude McCree ultimate
that's how I felt the downside to
exploding the roach though is that you
couldn't put it up on your wall yeah as
a trophy yeah I like to just nail them
like a deer head you know yeah just a
bunch of dead yeah that's sick yeah I
ate a bunch of game
this weekend [ __ ] yeah I went to a game
restaurant I had elk rabbit all right
whale all right Joe and uh bison I like
bison bison was good it was a short rib
too so it was like super tender you know
the elk was really good it's [ __ ]
good and then I had moose no I didn't I
didn't I did I would have filmed myself
if I had moose I would have like vlogged
it just for that that would be the
Tipping Point where people are like uh
yeah
hey guys
hey guys hey guys just killed a moose
I'm gonna eat it raw people like the
joke has gone a little bit too far hey
guys so we just hit a moose with the
with an Econo line I'm just gonna eat it
here what do you think man's blood
pouring down or I'm just kidding that's
[ __ ] up it's so dark stop it stop it
the Elsa is good the rabbit was good too
rabbit rabbit was good I mean all meat
is good the rabbit actually was a little
bit weird and the quail was also kind of
weird you never Quail before obviously
I've had no I've had I've had uh pigeon
one time squab that's it's called yeah
they brought it out with like the
[ __ ] claw still on it my wife get mad
at me because I eat the pigeon hit a
pigeon with a hammer and I tried to
explain to her squabbed but she don't
like it